what's up everybody welcome to another
things you missed here on gamespot com
courtesy of kind of funny I'm Nick this
is Greg Greg this is the final Batman V
Superman find this is like heartbreaker
you show us so much yet I want the movie
ouch 25th it's finally coming we've been
waiting forever after you haven't seen
me on the internet I'm kind of a crazy
Superman fan boy so I've been freaking
out about of these trailers going
through analyzing them and I've analyzed
this one yeah I'm gonna start it let's
get into it uh first things first I'm
batwing of course yeah hooray that we
finally get to see the good old Jeremy
Irons here running his Alfred right
Alfred Pennyworth which we even we heard
about right but it's actually cool and
we seen a little bit of it but here we
get a little bit more than grizzled
Alfred the old or Alfred you know I mean
and so just from the gym jump what's
interesting about it right is that you
know I like the idea that but yeah I
think usually when something happens
with the batwing when suit when Batman's
about to do something super heroic ah he
puts in an autopilot right right I like
here the scene that you know okay so
he's gonna go do it so he passes control
off to Alfred it was seemingly in the
Batcave or whatever they're 10 he's not
I'm gonna line it all up freeness ok
he's definitely in the Batcave this is
him at the back computer of course when
I say I don't be right now I'm gonna set
it for you in a second later you're
committed for this whole trailer by the
way which by the way you should have
watched before you started this but you
see you know what he's talking about
here in terms of like okay the guys are
over there you know two dozen dudes over
here I got this stuff now what's
interesting is this is from an earlier
trailer of course we saw this when
Batman comes in and then remember I
shoot all the stuff I would be shooting
people what's happening we assume
there's some kind of rubber bullets or
whatever in that the SUV he blows up
when I kill somebody right moving on
though in here we see the hostiles you
know I want to put you in here for me
this trailer is really about like hey if
you haven't didn't believe in this
moving you're a Batman fan we're giving
you the Batman trailer this of course
for me this screams for a million
different things it's definitely true to
the comics and what excuse me is the
Gimli Batman of course he looks short
ears bulky frame like Jim Lee's Batman
that I've known so well but this stuff
is screwed you know especially with the
Cape out like this this glide and it
just screams of you know the Gimli art I
always think of Batman from DC Universe
Online when he's hunched low and stuff
and yeah there's been
million of him swooping and breaking
through glass right there we get to see
it been after I kick some ass though of
course so here we got a bunch of dudes
I'll watching the door right now here's
what I want you to do this is gonna
sound dumb but stick with me remember
that door right to remember that exit
time just remember to remember make a
mental note for me Nick there thank you
he comes up the way you wouldn't expect
Batman see in a Ouija would but I you
know we wouldn't this is what this is
one of the reasons why i like this
trailer is because we've seen in the
last iteration of batman which is the
Dark Knight trilogy he kind of always
comes from the angle we would expect
which is like all right this to Dean
he's gonna come for the ceiling great
not the floor he doesn't he bursts
through the floor in this right which to
me made an impact i was expecting him to
drop down he didn't which i think is
indicative that we're actually like at
least someone on the zack snyder side is
thinking hey let's let's give people a
little something unexpected here ya know
one hundred percent let's give the
honestly this whole fight scene was
gonna go through a lot of the tools were
going to show you or he's gonna show us
remind me of the batman arkham knight
game batman arkham knight batman arkham
video games batman arkham asylum fake
cetera city uh one thing they're taking
out of I need your mental powers again
okay locked you're looking at all these
guns right yep they all look just
regular black guns right this happens
you'll just goes here everybody jerks
back and reacts here right look at that
red thing on there see that red light on
there yeah we just we just saw a whole
bunch of guns and saw no red lights but
it's almost as if Batman is shooting up
and doing something here see no red
lights there right and then all of a
sudden we got this dude here reacting
estas amigas hit his gun yeah exactly oh
no go back go back one no frame so we're
seeing right there there's actually
something attached to his gun now on the
right here yeah ya see that exactly
that's the you little three-dimensional
and he's going up into the rafters right
cool so stick with that just remember
that's not gonna come back for a long
time in this trailer but we're gonna get
right now is Batman just beating the
living tar out of the ten for which I
love which I love love love love look
this is what we're talking about you
know uh one thing with you know the
Batman from the Batman video games right
the Batman we know and love when we
think about comic books yeah we had a
couple dozen guys right that's not gonna
stop him he's not gonna get in there
he's not gonna have any trouble taking
those guys out and here we finally get
to see that version of Batman unleashed
right right I feel like you talk a
little bit about it with like the Batman
Begins stuff right there like that Bales
Batman was tough and awesome right but
we still didn't see him coming to these
kind of odds yeah we don't we don't
really you never really got a sense and
you have to be honest to yourself in the
in the dark knight trilogy
his Batman could actually physically
jump into a group of men and beat the
hell out of them right and I what I like
about here is that we're seeing that
momentum right where he's going from
person to person and he's striking
before the person before you even know
what's going on it's done that's already
over like a net head is in the freaking
ground as you rock bottom's this guy now
and then like here's a great one too if
you a frame by frame right he's still
got his grappling gun in his hand right
so he comes through he knocks that dude
loose so he can hit this guy over here
so you can come back come at this guy
right uses the grapple gonna slam down
the machine gun and then landis punch on
this dude and that just not gonna me
just get you moving and then this is the
one part where I was like I maybe it's a
bit too much he's running at him here
and I feel like that throw was the only
part where I seems like that seems a bit
too far maybe bring those boards in a
sec or whatever that I don't know but
again just like the video game now these
guys like I we're leveling up right here
were these guys and we got road knives
is gonna be he's gonna have an electric
electrified freaking Batman right there
can custom this man yeah yeah he won't
kill people but he's not afraid to put
you in the hospital for every yeah
you're in a lot of breathing machine
exactly exactly dang this guy it now
what's interesting is that right there
go back there this is what I love you
yeah exactly what we went there's this
line coming up from Ben Affleck as Bruce
Wayne or Batman to Alfred right where
he's like I'm getting slow my older
right and this is what he's got to be
referencing the fact that in the old
days nobody's ever touching them but
here is Kyle protects them from what
would have been pretty much death right
right across the back with spinal column
there but see that's why this is so
important to me right it's because this
Batman is using every tool at his
disposal to defeat these guys [ __ ] right
the cowl is supposed to be bulletproof
it's supposed to be fire [ __ ] is
supposed to be basically like another
sheet of armor that is on top of him
that also allows him to sort of glide
through the air we've seen all those at
this point right we've also seen the
fact that Batman is not a normal human
being he has a person who has trained
his body he is a tall human being he can
throw people look at this he can strike
someone threw for that guy's dead by the
way there's no one is also would it's
possible you're not you know he doesn't
remember the first 16 years of his life
but he's a lot guys fight you can't
speak just with the letter A means
anymore but sure line but know that
whole fight sequence amazing now here's
here's where we're in the Batcave now
what's interesting and what's important
to pull out of course is that earlier
you're saying theoretically he's at the
bat computer in the Batcave down right
in the center there we have were saying
about computer where Alfred was sitting
controlling the batwing you have what
you expect to be with a tarp draped over
at the Batmobile over to the right we
have the Jason Todd you assume Robin
suit that we've seen so many freeze
frame before with the haha joke's on you
written on it you already see the green
spray paint on it oh right so you know I
remember we first saw this I was like is
this there's that you know manner it
wasn't Wayne Manor and those out in the
middle of nowhere they look like you're
walking up to your wonder how scanner we
still don't as for as much as I feel
like we know about this movie we still
don't know how it all fits together most
together wasn't exciting but yeah this I
would say is the full blown back capers
well I also like this that I select the
design of this right it's very
industrial its variants all right like
when I saw it the first time oh I I saw
this in other trailers yes you've seen
the shot before yes I thought it was a
penthouse of some sort that had a cool
water feature in front of it sure now
that you actually stop and freeze it oh
is it is the Batcave yeah that makes a
lot of sense yeah but it's a very very
like utilitarian bad kid a Frank Lloyd
Wright I'd like my house to look like
that for sure I'd also like Jimmy hires
to be my Butler I did you I feel as
piecing together the best you can kiss
trailers jumbled everything up that this
jeremy irons conversation isn't
happening with Bruce in the room is you
a little further you get this shot Abreu
something this is happening concur no I
think he's talking over the comm system
he gets sliced across the back or
whatever in these I'm get slowed my old
age knees all right well you've already
lived long enough not to die an
interesting though if you look in the
background there is what looks to be the
armored suit that will become the Super
Man armor that we see prevalently in the
end of this method call right also is he
wearing a holster that's where those
suspenders yeah I know I know I don't
have an answer I think its holster you
want to know what my professional
opinion as Greg Miller shoot me a fanboy
in every window I think it's gonna be an
apron I think he's working on side he's
got that little my piece over it or
whatever but I mean I like that this
Alfred it has a little bit more of a hit
that past with him right lecture the
first thing we saw him in this trailer
specifically was a very militants like
sweater yet with the sort of army
patches and the army fixings all over it
he's taken more that a Geoff Johns
Batman year one deal you don't
immediately it was like you know when
they when alfred was like what former
british yes i love that
and i love that almost cursed in it no
big deal don't you have to beeping yeah
thanks there you go logo hooray hooray
another great logo now of course here
this is we've talked about this a
million times so we won't dwell on it
too much you assume the destruction the
destruction of Metropolis cuz that's
what we already knew this this scene
definitely when Superman Azad are
fighting we're about to see that I still
want to know who this girl is this I've
never bothered to think about it too
hard until I was watching this like I'm
trying to figure out what in please tell
me in the comments what I'm on Twitter
what this crashing is not what i was
taking weighs probably i guess when uh
what is their names Oh Zahraa busy busy
hora what's her name you know I'm
telling you for Tony India Zod's
right-hand woman yes Shh feel fair fair
day aria when she and Chris Meloni looks
at her and goes you're right good death
is its own reward and the chili bomb I
guess that would be then because the
next shot is him Fighting's on which is
which canonically happened sure I'm
staying with him when he was fighting
Zod remember it wasn't like all this
crap was shooting through the air they
be no reason for it on this this I mean
I think about the trajectory and how
much of that stuff's coming in right I'm
putting it out there maybe this is from
new stuff for the movie but sincerely
sincerely sincerely doubt it and I'm
sure the comments are gonna let me know
right away that yeah that's probably the
fee or a thing or this that or the other
because here we are still really want to
know this kid is is it just a Rando I
don't think it is Kevin's shave his head
yes you think it's Aranda it might be a
Rando here's my thing with being a
random here's I guess my thing when I
guess we see it i don't know if i see it
right away here and there fighting yeah
yeah but when Bruce runs into the
destruction that'll show up later in
this trailer that you've seen a million
times my whole thing is what would he be
running into just to do good sure he's
Batman he's Bruce Wayne he wants to help
people but I think the kid is the
motivating factor I think it's going in
to get the kid also then is that he's
kid what are we dealing with here we'll
figure it out March twenty fed will know
finally there we go one percent chance
are you again this is something we've
I've talked about a million times I mean
Oh over the last two years Fred a long
time I was like oh when I first saw the
screenshot I was like oh he goes to some
tribal thing and thought and then other
people point out that they like wearing
watches in suits and it's probably a day
of the dead yeah David from I'm sorry
Nick I'm sorry you knew so much about
boss long sorry I'm sorry that'll I know
you've California everyone sort of
I'll and go to other countries to get a
little more control in California I'll
be in another country yeah if you go Sal
far enough maitresse got a right Kevin
geographies here batmobile taken off no
license plate that's a problem that's
that's all he's all right he's a
billionaire you can afford it this is
the entire sequence that of course was
really Paul awesome though yeah it's
great sequence I wish I it's the same
thing as always as we've seen too much
this movie I love this I contact I hope
that's real but who knows the Batman
being a terrible driver slams into him
no big deal de soups in the Gotham City
gas Lux set everything up of course one
likes to do this thing over here it's
important to call up the flashing in the
background there that flashing light if
you've been keeping track of all the
other trailers there's that one where
they pull back and they're at Ground
Zero but there looks to be like the
tenth for like whatever circus is in
town that's pulsating with energy and
stuff I would imagine that's this and I
imagine that's of course where they're
bringing doomsday to life by using Zod's
body right this is a great moment again
we've seen it a million times now I'm
very excited to see it in context yeah
there we go they rise up Batman doesn't
back down remember how excited you were
the first time we saw this and you're
like we just change it up I remember
you're all stoked about goods dou u
stands up it's dope mix your penis
little bow let's go down let's go climb
stuff uh Batman is full on roofs are
really taking a breath the fights going
on fights gonna be come down here in a
second into some interesting stuff hey
Batman I love this him yet shot through
the roof yeah yeah this is awesome the
armor protecting but not I my my hold on
actually I can disprove my own theory
yeah this is before Superman's weekend
Suman obviously the trailer ends with a
you know the block punches you've met
looking at it now I think they should
give away how it happens in this trailer
I'm gonna show you in a second all right
but it looks like they go up here to
what would look to be where Superman or
whoever yeah where Batman's move the bat
signal right you would imagine that's
the best thing when they are casting
light on do you feel like that's the
show that's the other shot we saw from
like that very rare first glance where
he's standing there Superman comes down
into the rain if work yeah if we're
connecting everything I think this scene
begins with the yeah they're Batman's
next to that light he's moved into this
part of destroyed Gotham this part of
Gotham doesn't matter you see over there
you see on the left aboard a building
that lifts dilapidated he's doing he's
basically you know what everybody out
there gives man of steel so much trouble
for he's taking the fight to somewhere
no one can get started he's moved the
symbol there he's done that he's called
out super in so i think we start up
there we get back to the floor then we
get back up here and then one of the
things I'm talking about later on coming
up will be important so save that take
another mental and gotta all right
because we're not to put that together
you ready okay Malema shakin okay thank
you every time you ask me that's push
something else out she another what you
don't need to remember your anniversary
i love this very Clark Kent moment of
course we didn't get any of those really
in manistee no cuz you didn't take on
that persona right in there but you can
tell he's about to take it off and go
shoot up this is Bruce Wayne unveiling
his car of course that a another more
frank lloyd wright looking house out
there but this is the car that pulls up
in that original trailer with a violin
music urien you must be new to Gotham
you know here we go Clark and Lois happy
Lois Lane naked Clark loves her so much
wants to get in there and his jeans at
his t-shirt I love it is long sleeve
t-shirt this is good they don't dress
Superman Lois don't get to bang enough
and I like say I magic I like that this
is a darker more realer universe as
always say write the way to wrap your
head around the DC Cinematic Universe I
always say is that it is happening in
our world what if these gods came to our
world right now what if this is all had
to start happening this is how it would
play out at least that's what they think
right you know that's it's not the
Marvel Wayne know so I'm happy to but I
like this this shows a very human moment
with it work exactly shows character is
like a bull of him of a range of
emotions he's not just a boy scout
that's out there fixing the world sure
he's actually instead to Wow well that
was the thing is like I I mean with Man
of Steel being a big Superman fan I felt
their relationship not I thought it
progressed a bit too quickly when you
get started making out at the end on
Ground Zero and all the ashes and their
people are breathing in their dead
friends that was weird but I just that
was the one thing of like I got like how
they were connected but I didn't think a
jump to a romantic level as fast as it
did here this looks natural this looks
normal she's telling that they need this
of course we've seen that batarangs here
now remember when I told you remember
that exit sign mm-hmm there you go so
we're back to the beginning yeah well
we're back to a bat my first fight here
right but if you notice they flip the
image the exit signs backwards there so
for some reason we want in the trailer
cutting department they wanted to flip
this make it look more appealing to the
eye again so fast here we are again guns
are the guys these guys again that
suddenly have the red things on their
guns and we'll get to that one second I
suppose you remember guy hanging over
there Batman kicking some butt Batma
firma batarangs
blows on the left there no I had looked
into it trying a bit and I threw out a
bunch of different stuff like I mean I
start thinking about Oh Mac bizarre
Napa's are a star oh but I think it's
just a symbol I don't know maybe it will
be a game maybe we'll do something but
for me it didn't jump out please if it's
in the comments you know let me know or
tweet at me but it's just right there
triangle upside down with a circle in it
it didn't ring any bells for me like I
said maybe I got star oh no maybe kind
of no but probably not but that'd be
cool Oh Mac no probably not but cool you
know it's not though go forward
battering don't think gun cut up now
here we go I've told you to take a lot
of mental images yes do you know where
we are right now this is Superman being
weakened potentially we are back up
there in the center of the screen in the
back smoldering if you look in the
background I'm I'm saying that is the
bat-signal destroyed I'm saying it's
split you can see the lower ring of it
here okay that would have been the top
over it hey everybody on the camera top
/ smashed through and done now when I
first saw this in Batman fires this is
human catches much oh how ratty kalteek
off the grapple gun you're in a meme
like he's just trying get on with a
grapple gun that's not the grappling
know that is a little ball use some
kryptonite gas probably something that
like super he's gonna grab you like and
then it's gonna be what and then that's
how he's weakened that's how this fight
Batman you did you you didn't know
Batman he doesn't know that's nothing
that's what I like about this though is
that you don't know how he's gonna take
him on but it's not gonna be a
one-to-one fight that should I like
about this Batman it's not a one-to-one
fight he's got advantages that you don't
know of yeah that's Batman to me I'm
excited to see I can't wait for this
movie I bat bat wing doing its thing
here uh gal gadot good oat the goat
gadot I for all I was saying gal Godot
and then tim was in he's like no she
prances on T the T is there so good dog
I apologize to miss gadot I'm getting
lols us does she what a cool she doing
great uh well yes you've been around
forever I'm the johnny-come-lately
cousin Ashley's Wonder Woman Amin love
you know me but you you and Tim I was in
love with there was this vessel I was
gonna say you've been waving as fast and
furious like ever here she is getting
into a car that I was like soon kind of
looks like it could be that Bruce Wayne
car it isn't but it could be that is it
but it may be in our day but more
importantly look at the dress what if a
hand fancy red dress back backless I
love it very stylish right here we're
back to this fight right I also like
that has that it has sort of the that's
the great part about this is
in this movie is it's got flares of her
Oh chefs yeah you got a lot of gold of
gold yeah you did read yeah but what I'm
calling out with her is remember that
dress mental picture uh here we go
Batman's this after the weakening it
looks like over there fighting maybe
this is maybe this is the gas maybe that
thing blows up in his face he shoots out
that thing over there could be the bat
signal blown up again look like the
blonde a bad signal well we'll see we
have to wait and see on that one this I
am going back to it being this looked
like the shot they'd shown when they did
the brief flashback of Reese's payments
being murdered remember the comedian
from Wasserman walking with a little
Bruce Wayne and I remember this time
it's look it up Kevin you might have to
do a quick Google here remind me again
if who got announces Martha Wayne it was
recent which was weird because they'd
already shown Thomas Wayne forever ago
and then recently they're like oh and
now this person is Martha Wayne look oh
cool but i forgot who Kevin I'll have
that information by the end of it I
believe this is yet Joe Chill ice and
the parents back there right more the
fight throwing a wicked roundhouse I
think this is still this is after i'm
assuming he's after the weakening again
right we're suit wins weekend but he's
not perfect obviously you don't even
know why he say guys yeah blowing
through here ah this is again now when
it all gets very interesting and
convoluted to an extent right so this
explosion nothing new we've seen this
before we've seen you he's the doomsday
hitting we think Wonder Woman shield in
the last yes exactly in the last trailer
when that was all happening that's why
I'm hypothesizing it isn't I don't know
i can't i can't give you exact I don't
know what this is right but on this
frame you look around and it looks again
like a deserted area whereas I always
thought we were based around that
doomsday lightning dr. Frankenstein
structure i was talking about before
right but that was right downtown kevin
who we got is Martha Wayne lauren cohan
yeah Laura Cohen I forget who's that who
is that is that that's not Maggie from
walking that isn't as long a card it is
I think it's a little Maggie from the
walking dead Martha [ __ ] yeah thank you
for it was Laurel home black ipod it's
funny okay um but this one's the
Frankenstein chamber I was talking about
at Ground Zero was at Ground Zero
downtown metropolis this isn't downtown
metropolis right this is a you look
around look this looks like it's out it
like this is no the sticks this looks
like some kind of rendering plant you
know what I mean you look down here you
got these things it looks like there's
an oil refinery you know enemy and I
don't know if this plays into that
abandoned part that he
him to fight in you know I mean and
here's the thing because I was saying
before in the batman fight there looked
like it was abandoned right back man
lured in there at the bat signal get him
away from humanity right this goes on
and this is something I noticed for the
first time here this building over on
the left of the right of the frame
already effed up look it's already
gotten missing it a piece it's art and
this is looks like the original blast
for the most part obviously so I'm
wondering if this is actually maybe I
took this in the wrong direction maybe
this isn't the Doomsday fight this is
some batman bat bomb to weaken Superman
with red sunlight maybe you and I mean
maybe do you think the dilapidated area
is the ground zero the last place no I
don't like no cuz the ground zero of
last fight is in Metropolis and it's
that one with Superman I believe I
alright they had that awesome wall
around him with all the names of the
people who died right so I don't I can't
I no longer feel confident knowing at
what this is in the movie you know I
mean I don't know if it's the Doomsday
fight it might be may be the same thing
maybe Batman and Superman Wonder Woman
took them over here to have a one-on-one
and not have to worry about anything you
know whatever he's saving is these
property matters a lot of money with
this insurance claims i'm sure it's all
weighing stuff of course not here i
remember i told you to remember gals
dress right this is a different dress so
this is she's our she's going to another
fancy occasion to see the one only Bruce
Wayne or whatever I really really really
really really hope really hope they do
the justice league cartoon and make them
a thing like I'm not another thing but
there's a there needs to be a flirtation
right I hope they make him a full-blown
thing he likes I hope they get married
and have lunch a little bit exactly same
bets scheme Trevor's always like cuz
he's old you know I me because the world
war one period flick he's probably dead
actually but you know I'm sure they'll
find a way to make it just Chris prime
from pine but thats everywhere say Chris
Pine I say prime because you mean Chris
Pratt no I don't I mean you want to say
picturing your brain wants to say Chris
Pratt I think the more fun with you
after Chris kind of amazing as well this
is such a great line delivery to one
room is gonna be so good to everybody
sleeping on one woman right now start
acting like you care about Wonder Woman
everybody cuz my Anu he comes out you're
gonna care look at him smile well I like
remember nudelman an area now see here
we are back in the battle now down the
battle here this is the one she's going
in on she's going in on doomsday but if
you look here this structure over there
right again metally I guess that could
be a light thing to I'm trying to figure
out is this where is that big
explosion right is that big red
explosion setting this battle up or is
it part of the superman/batman battle
that we already know is in a dilapidated
it's got to be this battle cuz it looks
like the entire area has been destroyed
sure but they use many clever edits you
know what I need 30 I know and I was
jumping around here but I don't that
could that that metal scaffolding over
there thought could be another part of
the gas plant kind of thing in writing
maybe I don't know I'm excited not to
know me an awesome is an oil refinery it
would explain more of these fires that
are burning out of control for no reason
I like this jump move them god I can't
wait for this movie Logan who the hell
knows it is a car it's just in there as
an explosion right somebody do they did
it a peek now here's where it gets
interesting again Amy Adams underwater
right we know Aquaman's in this movie in
some capacity now you might think okay
what's going on why would she be
underwater and i would say i don't have
a good answer for you on why she's
underwater you don't I mean right I do
understand it there's maybe heat vision
blasts happening behind her maybe it is
just explosions whatever but I she's in
I believe I would need to dial it back
and luckily I can and I will eventually
but I don't wanna do it right now cuz
it'll be hard to get to this bus sure I
think this is the outfit she's wearing
when she she calls Lex Luthor a
psychopath oh I could be wrong possible
dial back you want a dial about I'm
gonna remember one 4405 got it good now
I'm gonna dial but you have to help me
feel time cuz if we get off track here
and I gotta sell time I can't do a mess
up your fun you're right no I don't know
if I am actually I think it is the pop
color the problem is that sort of for
outfit of choice I know yeah the popped
collar that were the best center there
okay a little vessel popped collar so
then ok so here well let's head back to
144 alright alright so now is it I want
you to remember that whole outfit that
she's arguing with Lex and I want it in
a second give you a pitch for how
Aquaman gets introduced in this movie ok
just a pitch could be wholly wrong who
knows so here she is she trying to out
of this thing heat vision maybe maybe
this is the release of doomsday right
possible and all hell breaks loose enjoy
fighting underwater she's got caught no
but the crazy name would never find
anyone anything but she also like lifts
her hands there to block herself it
looks like you don't I mean she blocking
or she's swimming upward I mean I
thought she was swimming for a while
because you always blow me water as soon
as if she's free he's blocking from
something she's that's a block right
there I don't think I ya know I think
she's are a key to the bullets that were
coming I think people are shooting a
doomsday or
Superman whoever the fine I like it's
not a second okay keep this mental image
do it mental walk thank you remarked
away can I like go up to the other ones
no sure let go the dress from one room
you don't need a I'm done thank you now
here's something very interesting in
fast motion when I thought I was seeing
is Batman up above as Batman should be
and then all these morons shooting the
whole Batman came out but after
extensive study of this because I am
Greg Miller and I love DC Comics I'm
making the hypothesis that they are once
again borrowing from the Arkham universe
and what happened is Batman shot through
the thing through those things that must
be some kind of magnets that attach to
the guns and then up here in his left
hand his right hand has the grandmother
grapple gun left hand he sets off a
sonic pulse that if you watch these guns
they're not shooting they're exploding
right so he's just like in Arkham he's
like pegged all the guns he's not
disabling so he can get down there and
just FB schools up with his fist which
makes sense if you were gonna take on
ten people with guns right exactly we
have to immobilize the guns then the
rest of us just chime you can see I mean
for surely guns are exploding and I I
assume they're from the little red
things better but we're also not say
those two back oh I guess they really go
off one by one it's like a chain effect
just like in the Arkham games that's
awesome very cool hope you got a cut
rock steady there you go punching this
is back to Metropolis this is that jet
that gets knocked out in front of Perry
Jenny and write what I Ron wasn't or
whatever the guy from Donna did I there
it goes off in the jet flies in there
and you assume Bruce Wayne in this car
driving down to ground zero to save that
girl I'm gonna pitch but who knows maybe
not maybe just going there to run into a
cloud of smoke fine over Gotham in the
batwing we assume Batman banking left
Batman shooting some stuff depressing
maybe a clever clip maybe he is shooting
shoot man he's probably to shoot
Superman with hood that way it's I'm
sure some was good as a lot of shooting
here again this makes me think that
again I mean so here's what's happening
I think this is still the abandoned city
battle with Batman and Batman has laid
this entire thing out as a giant trap
lures him there and then he's got the
smoke bomb and then he's got the guns
and he's just got turrets and he's just
like I'm lighting this kid up right this
guy won't stand a chance right none of
this is hurting him here's Martha Wayne
of course Diane Lane looks like after
the destruction of her Smallville home
she's a waitress again you know clever
cuts
but it does look like she'd be wearing
it she's wearing an apron there you know
enemy she's working in the small diner
Kent what do I say wait I apologize yes
Martha Kent effects I was like what the
Wayne very dead and as we discovered
Laura Cohen not dead I'm walking dead
Milwaukee dead spoilers for the walking
dead whatever lauren cohan in the
walking dead i just found out that she I
just remembered that two seconds ago I
made me from the walking dead right yeah
lay off him back I I claim to be the
expert at the Superman not at the
walking dead you laughs no I do
absolutely be expert along as well I do
actually everybody like a king googas
negan come in this season I can't Oh
alive Martha Kent far they can't i'm
assuming there's a TV in the background
no I'm in other news Superman's dead
she's like a woman traffic you can you
make that sound of back to her well
worth the Charlotte ready it's
Superman's dead oh really good really
good yeah I handling so good yeah here
we go fighting he's been weakened but he
survived and now that it all right now
here's where everybody who's putting on
their tin foil Greg Miller DC comics hat
right we already saw this a long time
ago this is the sod body being wheel
towards lex luthor right where he's
going to make news day and he's gonna
make doomsday uh in this little chamber
he clearly he's got guards he's got a
little laboratory maybe it's the
laboratory that gets all lightning
lightning a five there at the end or
whatever who knows on that one but
here's what I'm proposed that this Lex
Luthor is very much like Smallville Lex
Luthor and I won't get too far into but
if you remember I believe it was leveled
Kevin I need you to google this for me
to should have done this one to Google
from Smallville level 33 level 33 and a
third level 33.1 I forget what it was
new level 33 for small what it was is a
small villa clue thur started taking all
the people with powers and putting on
this thing and researching my doing all
this stuff what I'm hypothesizing is
Lexi's got this new thing here he's got
his new laboratory brings in the body
does all the search to it starts making
doomsday but he also has other
metahumans what is it 33.1 I was right
there on the last one 33.1 and he's
doing all this works but he's also been
collecting other metahumans like this
and so somewhere in here
here in this thing he's got Aquaman
captive you think so and so that then
when all hell breaks loose doomsday when
they wake him up it turns out to be a
monster he's like lightning meme and
everybody everyone lovers run away you
know Louis gets knocked off she's there
obviously cuz he did the whole like you
don't understand like little minds right
so he's with her he goes that takes her
downstairs or upstairs landing Bowl
reactivates the corpse forever or the
clone or whatever it's going to be then
she tumbles off of wherever they are
into the water got bolts are going off
that and that's Jason's big moment they
swim through there yeah he was Aquaman
safer jump out who are you and he's like
ah Blowfish haha glad you know I was
thinking more like the cage would break
that either holding him in like the
water take a break and he would just
like flip flop over to the water
diverter that's the last I see of him
that's true 10-second that's it auspol
but I like your way better it's a little
more dramatic my ways a little more
slapstick a comical here we go nice
little show banner now of course this I
took it for granted that if any exact
Snyder farts in the morning i get a
tweet about it right so I know all about
Batman V Superman I took for granted
that not everybody had been up that
Empire had released a whole bunch of
screenshots the magazine and one of them
was this now this all ties back in i
think the next couple frames are the
more of this where we remember this
scene where i was i originally when the
scene debuted i was like maybe there's a
bizarro Superman maybe lexus set up this
militant organization and they think
this or maybe Clark's finding out about
it for the first time and then toys came
out and this this version of Batman is
called nightmare Batman and so basically
I can't piece it together yet eat it but
basically I assumes through Wonder Woman
and the Greek gods and whatever her
powers are gonna be she or someone
related to her is able to give Batman a
vision and Batman gets to see the future
that's coming which is of course dark
side dark side is coming there why we
need the Justice League so here of
course the Omega symbol symbolizing dark
dark side here cut into the ground the
scorched metropolis or Gotham whichever
one you want it to be lava shooting out
very very much like apocalypse right and
then even here this is of course what we
saw later on with a Superman army you
have the parademons flying in dark sides
Bros dark side Burton little
guys again how it ties in I understand
if it's Bruce I understand it's Bruce's
worst fears but then how would he know
about dark side I don't understand if
it's a premonition but then I don't
understand the Superman army and why
Superman will be a guest Batman but then
we of course have been all been reading
injustice where we know that it could
happen yeah another one ? put it on
there right you're editing this right I
want a question mark right here I'm not
gonna do that okay Thank You parademons
come with you do that Superman angry
getting ready to fight again I'm a suit
and here's where it gets mixed up right
of where we are in the timeline anymore
you assume we are in the batman fight
still or is this the Doomsday fight the
fires are burning out of internal
doomsday fun the dude look at how much
chaos has been right but if Batman sets
off that big red fang you know what I
mean yeah I don't think Batman's
incident I understand I'm that's the one
thing I'm just putting it out there as a
thing I'm s not the kind of guy to lose
like a nuclear weapon if he had tears
against the guy he thinks he would take
a--take I mean this Batman is very
ballsy a wall he is pretty bold he's
very soon gonna run no Kim this is back
the rod like that this is the mining
again of like I understand first
responders running in there I don't
understand what his motivation to run in
there would be unless it's that little
girl right so we'll find it has to be
I'm worse 25th do you think it is I
think so I hope so hearing is this great
shot right as i summon my only critique
ears that i wanted a little green from
Batman to end it there but if you look
at it his face does riaz gonna say
something he's gonna say something his
face does really do you believe he's
already said that you will be alright
well bleep yeah well right that's Yoda
our movies are dumb this one's gonna
make more money than all the Star Wars
put together i love that look like a
spaghetti oh yeah that's cool that's
indefinitely and I so that's gotta be it
was this gotta be the first look punchy
throws after the bomb yeah you're after
the you know the thought of sausage yes
you look like we're still in that
environment on top of the rooftop god I
can't wait for this movie well Greg yeah
that was a very concise and quick I
don't know I'm sorry I don't know what
you want from me I'm gonna give you the
business now 11 i love
we caught in here greg was like it's
gonna be 10 minutes max I didn't know
the guy that I've only got three things
talk about no it's great but great thank
you so much for your time Greg as always
it's always nice learning a couple more
things that we missed in the trailer let
us know if we missed anything though
Greg had a couple questions if you guys
have the answers please leave them in
the comments below and as always i'm
nick underscore scarpino lynn turner
this is game over Greggy please follow
both of us and let us know what we got
right well we got wrong see you next
time and if you're Zack Snyder I'd like
to come to the premiere of this movie
I'll go I'll fly anywhere in the world
if you're Zack Snyder you got better
things to do than watch anything that
these two knuckleheads make